Long hôm nay mình sẽ dạy các bạn về Tin
Học lớp 12 bài về à HTML và cấu trúc
trang
web thì hôm nay mục lục mình sẽ có là
giới thiệu về trang web và HTML cấu trúc
cơ bản của một tệp HTML và phần mềm soạn
thảo
HTML thì đầu tiên trang web thì các bạn
thực ra là nếu mà các bạn s sử dụng máy
tính hiện nay thì các bạn sẽ thấy là các
bạn sử dụng trình duyệt tr lướt web rất
là nhiều thì ở đây trước khi vào bài
mình sẽ cho các bạn xem một ví dụ ví dụ
Giả sử đây là trang web Tuyền sinh 247
thì bản chất Đây là một cái trang web
Hoặc là các bạn có thể lên Facebook hoặc
là thậm chí là trang Google bất kỳ trang
nào bằng chính duyệt thì đều là một
trong web cả thì cách để các bạn biết
được là
Cái này là về giao diện cho người dùng
nhìn thấy thôi Còn bây giờ để các bạn
biết được à cái trang này nó có bố cục
như nào làm th nào để làm ra trong web
này chẳng hạn thì các bạn thường là mình
đang dùng là dùng Microsoft ed bạn có
thể ấn Ctrl U để mà xem xộc code view
xộc như này nó sẽ nhảy sang để xem được
xc code của một trang web thì ở đây Các
bạn thấy có rất rất nhiều rất là dài
nhưng đại khái thì nó
là đoạn code để làm nên cái trang web
cái đoạn Các bạn cứ Hình dung là mình gõ
ra những cái đoạn này sau đó thì mở bằng
trình duyệt thì nó sẽ ra cái trang web
như thế này để các bạn nhìn thấy đấy thì
thì bây giờ mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn về
việc là làm thế
nào Làm thế nào để mà mình làm ra được
một cái trang web dựa trên
HTML thì HTML là gì đã HTML nó sẽ là ví
dụ ở đây mình có gõ trước một đoạn Mã
codde à nó sẽ khi mà bạn mở bằng chịnh
duyệt thì nó sẽ ra cái giao diện kiểu
như này nó sẽ không ra cái mã code của
mình đã gõ mà nó sẽ hiểu được là như thế
này đấy thì ở đây sẽ có khái niệm là thẻ
đánh dấu HTML thẻ đánh dấu Tức là sao
thẻ đánh dấu tức C nó sẽ là những cái
Các bạn thấy ở đây nó có màu khác cái
màu trắng này thì thể hiện việc là nội
dung còn màu hồng nó đang thể hiện việc
là nó là các bộ thẻ của HTML đấy thì các
bạn thấy là có thẻ body thẻ H1 thẻ p thẻ
HR thẻ p đấy Đây là những thẻ của HTML
đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ thử mình cứ nghĩ
mình sẽ thực hành trực tiếp để cho các
bạn dễ hình dung mình sẽ dùng phần mềm
là subtech đây phần mềm miễn phí các bạn
có thể tải về trên
mạng mình sẽ mở một file
mới mình sẽ ấn Ctrl s để lưu lại lại
index.htm này chẳng
hạn khi mà mình gõ học cái ngôn ngữ này
thì mình đặt tên file mình đặt tên thế
nào cũng được A B C X yz đều được nhưng
đuôi nó vẫn phải có đuôi file là ch HTML
để hiểu để trình duyệt sẽ hiểu à Đây là
một tài liệu HTML thì nó hiển thị đ
Chuẩn đấy tiếp theo là mình sẽ gõ dụ dụ
Giả sử mình chỉ gõ H1 như này thẻ H1 này
do nội dung bên trong này xin chào các
bạn Đấy xong rồi đóng thẻ như này đấy
các bạn sẽ thấy là ở đây mình có mở thẻ
sau đó ghi tên của thẻ xong rồi đóng
ngặc nhọn xong rồi tên nội dung xong rồi
mở thẻ xong ph gạch chéo như này vì mình
đang dùng cái công cụ gõ code nên nó sẽ
gợi ý việc mình à nó sẽ hiểu được được
là mình đóng luôn bằng thẻ H1 chứ không
mình không phải gõ thủ công H1 này nữa
chỉ cần cách chéo như này là nó sẽ tự
động gõ nốt phần cần lại cho mình Bây
giờ mình có thể chạy nó bằng cách là
chuột phải vào chọn mở bằng trình duyệt
như này hoặc các bạn có thể mở mở file
tìm cái file Ở mình đang mở ở desktop
các bạn Thể Tìm cái file này mở nó lên
bằng trình duyệt ví dụ giả sử ở đây các
bạn xem thì đây nó sẽ hiển thị dạng như
này
đây là nội dung mình gõ nó là có chữ H1
rồi có thẻ các thứ các thứ nhưng cách
hiển thị của trình duyệt sẽ khác với cái
mình đã gõ bởi vì nó sẽ hiểu được đ đoạn
code này bạn đang muốn thể hiện việc
hiển thị H1 nó tượng trưng cho
heading 1
heading là thẻ kiểu liên quan đến tiêu
đề Nó phóng nó làm chữ cỡ chữ to hơn
cũng như là làm in đậm hạn Một là thể
hiện là là độ lớn của nó mặc định là 1
lớn nhất 6 là nhỏ nhất thì đang có h
hding 1 đây mình sẽ thử gõ cho các bạn
ví dụ thẻ H3 để so sánh Đây là bài
học đây mình gõ Hàn có dấu nhá nhá Đây
là bài học HTML đấy như
này các bạn thấy là đây các bạn sẽ thấy
là rõ ràng là chữ này to hơn chữ này rất
nhiều bởi vì đây
sữ khác biệt giữa H1 về H3 đúng không ạ
thì các bạn vừa được Thấy qua về demo về
HTML thì các bạn sẽ thấy là thế còn
những cái kiểu thêm những cái dòng này
để làm gì Rõ ràng em thấy có mỗi H1 với
H3 là nó ra được cái trong web rồi thì
toàn bộ những cái này nó là gì thì mình
mình sẽ đi từ từ đã mình sẽ đi đến cái
phần hai sau
Tiếp đầu tiên HTML là viết tắt của
hypertext marup language ờ để mà dịch nó
ra thì sẽ là ngôn ngữ đánh dấu siêu văn
bản nhưng mà mình thực ra là theo mình
thì không cần phải cố dịch mấy cái từ
tiếng Anh chên ngành này các bạn chỉ cần
biết được viết tắt của nó HTML là gì và
tiếp theo là gõ cú pháp nó như nào cú
pháp nó luôn nằm trong cặp
dấu dấu ngoặc nhọn như thế này đúng
không ạ và mục đích của nó là để hiển
thị ra nội dung của một trang web đây
tiếp theo Các bạn
đây mình sẽ cho các bạn xem lại một tí
nhá
thì mình sẽ đi sâu vào cái phần H1 thẻ p
HR vào thẻ p này thì một cái phần tử
HTML nó khác với cái thẻ đánh dấu HTML
nhá là nó sẽ gồm cả thẻ HTML nó sẽ
là mở thẻ này tên của thẻ và nội dung
của thẻ sau rồi đóng thẻ như thế này thì
đây là đây là toàn bộ là phần tử HTML
thì các bạn sẽ thấy nó sẽ ví dụ cái dòng
này này nó là một một dòng này là một
phần tử này dòng này một phần tử này
thậm chí đây cái dòng HR này cũng là một
phần tử nhưng mà cái phần tử này nó sẽ
luôn là thẻ đánh dấu HTML luôn bởi vì nó
thẻ đặc biệt nó sẽ không có nội dung ở
bên bên trong tại sao như thế thì các
bạn xem lại bên này một tí thẻ HR này có
tác dụng là gì Ví dụ nhá thẻ H1 này thì
nó sẽ có chứa nội dung bên trong nó là
trang web và HTML nó cố để hiển thị ra
là thẻ tiêu đề nên là nó sẽ bối động và
chữ to và thẻ P là paragraph là thẻ văn
bản thì nó sẽ chẳng cần hiển thị trên
màu màu mè gì cả nó nó hiển thị ra bình
thường còn HR là một thẻ đặc biệt là nó
không cần nội dung ở giữa nó chỉ là thẻ
để mà nó một dòng kẻ ngang như thế này
đấy nên thành ra nó không cần có nội
dung ở giữa nó một thẻ đặc biệt và đây
là một thẻ HTML thẻ thẻ tác HTML kiêm tử
HTML luôn và cuối cùng là thể p hai B cà
nó giống nhau đúng không
ạ Đấy nên là khi vừa rồi mình sẽ trả lời
cho các bạn cái câu hỏi 1 này trên sách
giáo khoa các bạn thì hình 7.1 đúng
không ạ Có bao nhiêu phần tử HTML thì
mình đến ở đây các bạn sẽ để ý là đây 1
2 3 4 cái thẻ h này sẽ có đóng ở đây nhá
5 6 7 8 9 đấy mình sẽ gồm chín phần tử
thẻ HTML này nó mở và đóng ở đây thẻ h h
này mở đóng thẻ body mở đóng và nội dung
này đúng không
ạ Đấy thì như mình vừa nói
thì sự giống là khác nhau giữa thẻ HTML
thì trong một vài trường hợp là thẻ HTML
và phân tử HTML nó giống nhau Nó là 1 ví
dụ với HR này chẳng hạn nó là mỗi thẻ
thôi và nó cũng kiêm luôn là bởi vì nó
thẻ đặc biệt nên nó sẽ không có nội dung
ở giữa còn thường là thẻ HTML là nó sẽ
chỉ có mỗi cái mở đóng thẻ và tên của
thẻ còn nội dung ở giữa thì không có nên
là phần tử HTML nó sẽ ôm luôn cả HTML và
nội dung của nó đây kết hợp giữa thẻ Mở
nội dung và thẻ đóng còn thẻ atml sẽ chỉ
bao gồm phần mở đầu và kết thúc của phần
tử đúng không ạ tiếp theo cấu trúc cơ
bản của một TP
HTML thì ở đây các bạn như mình phân
tích thì các bạn sẽ thấy là vừa nãy Vừa
nãy rõ ràng là anh chỉ gõ mỗi đây H1 với
H3 em cũng thấy ra được một trong web
rồi đúng không ạ Thế rốt cuộc thì cái
toàn bộ cái phần dâu cái phần do 2 này
là gì đấy HTML thêm cái này head và body
nó đều làm gì đấy
thì thường là cấu trúc của một t phá tml
nó sẽ có ba phần một là khai báo phiên
bản đây là nhìn thế này thôi nhưng thực
ra đây là khai báo phiên bản html5 là
mới nhất bây giờ đang dùng còn mình nhớ
là cái khai báo phiên bản cũ hơn thì nó
dài dóng hơn và nó cũng phải ghi rõ cụ
thể ra Tại sao phải khai báo phiên bản
như thế bởi vì là nó còn liên quan đến
các trình duyệt nữa đương nhên đương
nhiên bây giờ mình đang đều dùng trình
duyệt mới nhất rồi ví dụ là chome à
Firefox hoặc là Opera cố Cố thậm chí là
Microsoft Edge đúng không ạ thì đều dùng
cái mới nhất và đều hỗ trợ HTML mới nhất
làm năm nên các bạn sẽ khai báo này hoặc
các bạn không cần khai báo Mấy trình
duyệt đấy sẽ hiểu là các bạn đang dùng
cái phiên bản mới nhất Nhưng mà nếu mà
giả sử mà các bạn làm trong một cái
trang web từ lâu rồi Từ cũ rồi nó hỗ trợ
những cái cũ hơn thì các bạn phải khai
báo
nhưng mà cái m html5 này mình nhớ là ra
cách đây cũng phải tầm 20 năm rồi nên là
bây giờ các bạn cứ yên tâm khai báo như
thế này là được tiếp thì đương nhiên là
tệp tài liệu HTML thì sẽ phải trong cái
bộ thẻ HTML nhưng nó không phải là một
cái phần gì cả mà nó sẽ chia hai phần là
phần head và phần body mình xin phép nói
trước một phần h một tí cái này không có
trong sách lắm nhưng mà mình cảm thấy nó
Nó là một cái khá hay nếu các bạn đã
nhắc đến phần hé đây mình sẽ ví dụ các
bạn dễ hình dung hơn Ví dụ ở đây mình có
cái trang web này
à mình xin phép vào Google một tí tra dụ
Giả sử bây giờ Idol của vài bạn thì sẽ
ra khá bảnh chẳng ạ
Đấy đấy thì gõ cái này nó sẽ ra khá
nhiều thông tin đúng không ạ Các bạn
thấy
là đây là công cụ tìm kiếm và nó sẽ ra
được những cái đây gọi thumbnail là
những cái ảnh nhỏ và cả tiêu đề đúng
không ạ Làm sao để công cụ tìm kiếm nó
biết được là cái trang web này nó có cái
ảnh này Ví dụ mình bấm vàoo đây nhá u
trang này trang này có rất rất nhiều ảnh
các bạn thấy có rất nhiều ảnh có cả
video Làm sao để nó nó hiểu được lấy cái
ảnh này đúng không ạ thì công cụ tìm
kiếm nó cũng là máy tính và và nó cũng
sẽ phải đọc cái file HTML của mình đây
Các bạn thấy chấm đuôi file HTML không ạ
BN các bạn có thể ấn Ctrl u này các bạn
xem X code này thì các bạn sẽ thấy ở đây
có khái niệm và thẻ Meta và nó sẽ có
inmate này Đấy cái đường link của cái
ảnh thăm vừa rồi nó chính là cái đường
link như thế này để ra được cái phần
head đây nó sẽ nằm hết ở phần H Các bạn
thấy không thẻ Meta nằm trong phần h đại
khái thì các bạn cứ hiểu là phần h và
phần chứa những cái thứ mà không hiển
thị ra cho trình duyện à không hiển thị
ra người dùng bình thường nhìn thấy mà
hiển thị mà kiểu nó sẽ để cho những công
cụ hỗ trợ những công cụ tìm kiếm Ví dụ
Google thậm chí là Facebook nó có thể
hiểu được à trong web này đang muốn có
một nội dung là gì vậy Các bạn thấy ở
đây nó sẽ có content nội dung này nó sẽ
bao gồm cả thẻ tiêu đề này Tóm tắt này
vân vân vân đấy thì để công cụ h công cụ
tìm kiếm có thể hiểu được ví dụ Trang
đấy đã viết vào ngày bao nhiêu đấy Tiêu
thai thồ tiêu đề là gì đấy đấy Mọi thứ
nó sẽ nằm ở trong phần h cái phần mà
người dùng không nhìn thấy thì thì ngược
lại phần h thì mình có phần body tức là
phần những cái phần mà mình muốn người
dùng mình nhìn thấy thế nên là nhiều nếu
mà nhiều người thắc mắc là tại sao có
đầu có thân rồi sao không có chân đúng
không ạ Không có vút bởi vì rõ ràng là
mình sẽ chỉ có hai phần thôi một phần là
cho công cụ tìm kiếm có thể biết được
trang web mình đang có nội dung là gì và
phần body là nội dung cho người dùng
nhìn thấy
đấy thế nên là vừa rồi Khi mà mình gõ gõ
như này không khai báo một cái gì cả
đúng không ạ thì trình duyệt sẽ tự động
hiểu à Đây là làm hết trong phần body là
phần người dùng nhìn thấy đấy được được
không ạ Đấy tiếp theo là theo như ở
trong sách giáo khoa các bạn đề cập thì
bản chất là cái sơ đồ của cái HTML nó sơ
đồ hình dạng cây nó sẽ kiểu có từ gốc Là
HT HTML này xong rồi nó sẽ có chia mà
cấp C đấy thì sẽ là có head body cùng
cấp này các bạn thấy cung cấp head body
này title là nằm trong head nên mình lùi
vào một cái đúng không ạ
tiếp theo body sẽ có h1p hrp tất cả cung
cấp hết thì mình đã viết cho nó cùng
Ngang Hàng nhau các bạn hiểu là nó cùng
cùng một tra là cùng Body và Tra lớn
nhất là HTML
đấy thì tương tự như thế thì mình đã vẽ
viết trả lời cho các bạn cái câu ở trong
sách giáo khoa là vẽ sơ đồ cây của đoạn
văn bản HTML sau mình đã viết lại cho nó
nó dễ nhìn hơn một tí đấy theo cách viết
của mình từ sách giáo khoa là các bạn
nếu mà nhìn thế này các bạn sẽ nhìn rõ
luôn thể P ở đây mở ở đây đóng ởo đây
Thằng này sẽ là cha của những cái thằng
con này thể P ở đây Cái này thằng Chữ
đậm này này nó Con của cái thằng p này
bởi vì nó nội dung mà nội dung của thằng
p nên mình sẽ lùi vào như này Đấy lùi
vào các bạn nhìn thấy rất là rõ thằng
đậm này nó sẽ nằm ở trong thẻ p này thẻ
B này thẻ b là thẻ in đậm thẻ I là
italic là in in nghiêng này u là
underline là cái dưới này đấy các bạn sẽ
nhìn thấy nó sẽ rõ ràng là thẻ P là cha
của mấy đứa này đúng không ạ tiếp thì
cây HTML có bao nhiêu phần tử gốc thực
ra là nó chỉ có một phần tử gốc thôi là
kiểu gốc dễ vừa rồi mình nói về cái cây
ạ thì cái gốc của nó chỉ có một cái đó
chính là thẻ HTML to này sẽ chứa toàn bộ
những cái thẻ bên trong nó đấy đây phần
tử gốc là thẻ HTML được không
ạ tiếp theo mình đến phần mềm soạn thảo
văn bản soạn thảo HTML thì vừa rồi mình
có cho các bạn thấy là dùng subex có
cũng có thể gõ được nhưng mà Thậm chí
các bạn thể dùng phần mềm ngay không cần
cài đặt là phần mề notp hoặ thậm chí là
các bạn nào mà thích kiểu tá bạo hơn thì
các bạn thể dùng word nói chung là bất
kỳ cái gì mình chỉ cần lưu là ch HTML
mình đều có thể mở lên bằng trình duyệt
Ví dụ mình ở đây có một cái trông rất là
hay Rất là sinh động một cái trang web
người ta gõ bằng notp vây là mình đây
mình thử gõ các bạn bằng
đấy các bạn có thể dùng gọ
file này mình sẽ Open qui
bạn thấy mở lên nó vẫn nó vẫn là ra ra
cái code của mình thôi nó không khác gì
cả nó chỉ khác ở điểm là nó không có m
hiển thị dạng như này và nó không có gợi
ý gì cả không gợi ý gì cả ví dụ là H1
như này Đấy xong rồi đây mình thử gõ lại
nha Xin chào các bạn xong mình đóng như
này không gợi ý việc đóng cho mình đấy
không có màu sắc gì cả
đấy này ABC như này chẳng hạn đấy các
bạn thấy không hề gỡ ý mình thể lưu lại
và việc mở lên thì mình chỉ cần tải lại
trang tải lại cái file mà các bạn vừa
nãy đã mở và sẽ ra được nội dung mới đấy
đúng không
ạ thì rõ ràng Các bạn thấy là nếu mà gõ
bằng HTML gõ soạn thảo HTML mà dùng mà n
pass thì nó khá là kiểu tù túng kiểu
dạng là không thân thiện nó lắm các bạn
có thể sử dụng những cái phần mềm miễn
phí nó gọi là mã nguồn mở đấy mã nguồn
mở tất cả nó miễn phí cho mọi người có
thể tải về để sử dụng đấy ví dụ là notp
cộng cộng nop cộng cộng nghe nó giống
kiểu phiên bản nâng ca hơn của notp đấy
hoặc spch Nhưng mà mình đang cài cái hai
cái này nó n nạ nó cũng rất nhiều điểm
tương đồng với nhau chỉ có khác một điểm
đây mình cho các bạn xem nhá Đây nó là
cái mình ấn tượng đầu tiên đó là cái
tông nền của Cái này là màu trắng còn
cái kia là màu tối mình nghĩ là làm việc
làm việc gõ nhiều thì mình quen Nhìn cái
tối hơn đây
á qu đy mình mở trong Index đây đấy các
bạn thấy không đây để mình cho các bạn
nhìn để so
Cái phần mềm này cả hai phần mềm đều là
Ph phần mềm hỗ trợ gõ HTML và giao diện
n ngoài việc là nó thân thiện cho việc
gõ HTML ra nó có những cái tiện ích để
mà gõ HTML tốt hơn cái này các bạn có
thể lên mạng người tự tìm hiểu thêm là
những cái tiện ích đấy những cái Pit đấy
hoặc là extension đấy để
cài để mà còn phục vụ cho những cái buổi
sauu ngồi gõ HTML thay vì các bạn dùng
notp thì cái việc gõ nó khó hơn về cả
vệc cỡ ý cũng như là màu sắc kiểu nó
không thân thiện đúng không
ạ
đây còn cả vs code nữa vs code thì mình
thấy là dành cho hẳn một người Làm lập
trình viên chuyên nghiệp cũng cũng có
thể sử dụng cái
này đây tiếp theo Nếu giả sử là các bạn
không muốn cải về máy giả sử là máy các
bạn các bạn không có máy tính cá nhân
Các bạn phải dùng tạo ở nhà trường mà
không được cài Mấy cái phần mềm gì cả
cũng như là đại khái Thì máy các bạn Hy
dung lượng rồi thì các bạn có thể lên
những cái trang những cái trang này là
những trang hỗi trợ kiểu gõ soạn thảo
HTML trực tuyến thậm chí ví dụ cái trang
này nó ngoài
việc hỗ trợ soạn thảo đôi khi là nó sẽ
có những cái mẹo những cái gợi ý kèm cả
khhoa học miễn phí
thì các bạn hoàn toàn thể thực hành bổ
sung thêm kỹ năng ở trên này kết hợp với
những cái khóa học để mà các bạn kiểu
cải thiện thêm vốn hiểu biết vân vân bởi
vì cái này là nó là một cái để kiểu các
bạn học web làm soạn Hảo mọi thứ nhanh
hơn đây ví dụ đây ở trang w3 school đấy
tiếp bây giờ mình xin phép trả lời những
câu câu hỏi có trong sách tiếp nhá
cái câu là xếp thành hai nhóm mình đã
xếp sẵn ở đây cho các bạn đó ví dụ là
chạn Thảo HTML mình có thể dùng
Notepad mình có thể dùng subex hoặc
Notepad cộng cộng trình diệt web thì bây
giờ có rất rất nhiều chình m web ví dụ
Opera Chrome cc cốc Firefox hay là
Microsoft đúng không ạ Ngoài ra là bây
giờ thực ra còn rất nhiều nhưng mà trong
sách chỉ nói những cái tiêu biểu nhất
bây giờ
thôi tiếp theo là đây câu này Thực ra là
câu mà chính các bạn nên tự kiểu cảm
nhận sự khác biệt như mình đã nói nhưng
mình xin phép nói qua trước ở đây có
những cái thứ nhất là nó liên quan đến
việc là Hiển thị Màu sắc này như bạn vừa
nãy đề cập
Các bạn thấy rõ là giữa một cái Supply
text với một cái tắt cái nốp rồi cái
Supply tch một cái phần mềm chuyên nghệp
đúng không ạ một cái soạn Hảo thông
thường là kiểu n pass thì màu sắc nó
khác biệt hẳn tiếp theo là phần tự động
hoàn thành mã giống như các bạn vừa nãy
thấy là cái H1 khi mình đóng thẻ là lập
tức nó sẽ tự động đóng Không cần phải
ghi chữ H1 nữa đấy tiếp là phần kiểm tra
lỗi hay là những công cụ khác để hỗ trợ
cho việc gõ ví dụ là về sau nó sẽ gợi ý
bạn là bạn quên chưa đóng thẻ này Đấy
vân vân nữa thì tất cả những cái đấy
những cái phần mềm chuyên nghiệp nó sẽ
có và đặc biệt là hầu hết đều là miễn
phí
đấy thì vừa rồi là mình đã giới thiệu
qua về HTML cũng như là cách để mà soạn
thảo được một cái tài liệu HTML để hiển
thị ngoài ra là mình muốn cho bạn xem
qua một cái trang web cũng n là giống
cái trang hỗ trợ soạn thảo HTM trực
tuyến này thì các bạn Thể thỏa sức sáng
tạo tham khảo dụ là mình có trang COD
pen như thế
này ví dụ là các bạn đến đây Các bạn nên
tra đây tra nước ngoài nên các bạn nên
tra bằng tiếng Anh ví dụ giả sự là mình
liên quan đến phần đăng nghiệp chẳng hạn
đấy thì nó sẽ ra những cái giao diện rất
là màu m rất là đặc đẹp ở đây để các bạn
thể tham khảo các bạn thể à mang cái
code giao diện này về trong web của mình
đấy ví dụ mình bấm vào đây đ xem đây nó
sẽ có HTML và CS nữa CS là gì thì chắc
về sau các bạn sẽ được học các bạn hoàn
toàn thể C cái này ví dụ mình sẽ ví dụ
luôn ở đây các bạn dễ h dung các bạn C
như này đây set này set thì luôn nằm
trong cái thẻ nó là thẻ Style như
này Đấy sau đó thì mình mở chạy thử đó
các bạn thấy nó đã ra được một giao diện
của trang web rất là màu mè mình không
cần phải biết một tí gì về làm giao diện
mình vẫn thể sao ché được cái giao diện
từ trang web khác về để làm nhưng mà
mình vẫn phải hình dung được là Ừ mình
mình sao chép về Nhưng mà mình muốn sửa
lại đúng không ạ ch login này đổi thành
đây tiếng Anh mình đổi thành tiếng Việt
là đăng nhập chẳng hạn đúng không ạ Đấy
th nó hành đăng nhập đó thì rõ ràng là
mình hoàn toàn thể lên mạng mình xem cái
giao diện nào đẹp mình sửa lại đấy cũng
như là mình thay đổi để vì mình đã hiểu
được là trang web đấy nó tạo bởi HTML
đúng không ạ Ok chắc là buổi hôm nay
mình sẽ tạo dừng tại đây hẹn gặp lại các
bạn ở buổi sau